me and a friend of mine were recently talking about loneliness
especially how it affects mothers
so allow me to ramble for just like a hot second
because one of the most profound feelings in motherhood that I experienced
especially when I had 202 and was like a full time stay at home mom
was loneliness
and the isolation that comes just naturally with being a stay at home mom
now a lot of the times in the media right now we're hearing about this like
male loneliness epidemic
but can we talk about for a second
why it is so jarring for women in motherhood to experience this
and that is because there is nothing more in community than women in their youth
women and their friend groups are these dynamic
little communities within themselves
and there's nothing that takes away that sense of community than having a child
whether you're the first or the last or the one who decides not to have kids
one of your friends having kids drastically changes the friend group
and I don't know about y'all
but like most of my best friends I made in college
so we all went off to our own corners of the universe after that
and I was the first to have kids
so when we talk about loneliness for mothers
when we talk about loneliness for being stay at home moms especially
it's not just that we're alone and we're experiencing loneliness
it is that we're experiencing loneliness
after already experiencing this great sense of friendship and community
being alone in your house all day is not the way mothers were supposed to mother
we were supposed to have this continuation of these female relationships
that's what we talk about when we're talking about a village
we're not talking about the dad participating
although that is 100% expected and necessary
but we're talking about these female groups of companionship
women have always thrived in community of women in the company of women
and we were not supposed to go from girlhood and friendships and community
into our womanhood
and then isolated in motherhood
there is a reason to feel so lonely and it's because it's unnatural
and that was a product of the nuclear family and the Industrial Revolution
and white supremacy
if we wanna go that deep
if you're ready for that